there's been a lot of criticism of the
preseason because we don't see the
starters play used to be a full half
maybe more for the third preseason game
the other side of the coin and what you
need to know this morning when starters
play folks starters can't get injured it
happened to panthers quarterback cam
newton who ended up in a walking boot
after the thursday night game against
new england patriots on this sack he got
his foot ankle etc injured they were
looking at it on the sideline he walked
to the locker room but after the game
walking boot and here is ron rivera you
can just tell by the tone of his voice
that he is not happy with the outcome
here's ron rivera chris from after last
night's game
he's in a walking boot that's all i can
tell you
what did you see on the actual play
he got sacked
that's about all i saw
do you know what might have happened
when he was cutting in the
joe i i can't tell i don't know i don't
know
i don't know when i get a chance to
watch tape i might know but i don't know
chris here we are 16 days away from week
one rams at panthers and as of right now
we don't know if cam newton's going to
be able to play all because of yet
another injury that happens during a
preseason game yeah it is uh first off
when you look at the play itself it did
not look like anything egregious
happened right mike i mean it almost
like he just jammed his ankle or foot
into the turf uh i don't i don't know i
don't see anything specific to go oh
that's exactly where he did it but
either way you could tell ron rivera is
concerned you're exactly right about
that mike and he should be we talked
about this a little bit on my unbuttoned
podcast yesterday the carolina panthers
backup quarterback situation is one of
the worst in football i believe
it's trouble that team is not the same
without cam newton and they're flirting
with that situation or a disaster with
that situation with the guys they have
him backing cam newton up and yes i mean
i i think carolina's a playoff team with
cam newton this year you know or at
least borderline in that conversation if
he's not out there then they're they're
just an average football team they're
going to be nothing they're going to be
middle of the road maybe below average
and i think that's where ron rivera
maybe some of that reality set in during
the press conference
and chris general manager marty herney
was on a radio show after the game last
night and he said we're hoping it's not
too bad we'll find out more tomorrow but
i hope it's not too bad there's
something ominous floating around in
those words yeah
if it is too bad then maybe it's who
knows how long cam newton misses but you
go hey west virginia great will greer
gets an opportunity kyle allen taylor
heineke yeah the depth chart behind cam
newton is not an impressive one and
chris chris the name that's going to
come up
oh i know especially with eric reid on
that team eric reid is going to sound
the alarm if cam newton is out for any
extended period of time just like torrey
smith last year the panthers receiver
who lobbied publicly for eric reid to be
signed when the panthers had a needed
safety i guarantee you that tory smith
and eric reid are going to say hey it's
time to bring colin kaepernick to
carolina and give him a chance to be the
replacement for cam newton i said two
years ago when cam newton was recovering
from ankle surgery get colin kaepernick
for the offseason program have an
understanding that once cam newton's
healthy you'll let him go but at least
it gives everyone a chance to see colin
kaepernick is capable of showing up at
practice and and the franchise is not
going to disband the next day so uh
that's going to be the next step in all
this i believe if we find out that cam
newton is going to miss anything more
than a week or two yes i i mean i hear
you mike i don't think it will happen
i'm sure people will clamor for it from
pure football standpoint it would make a
lot of sense he really he fits what that
carolina panthers offense wants to do
you know it's a little bit of its own
concoction of an offense there's not
really one out there like it as far as
what they do because of cam newton's
skill set and colin kaepernick um ding
ding ding has a similar skill set as
well so i hear you but i just don't
think it's going to happen coaches him
being three years out of the league the
attention we've discussed all that uh
and i don't think other thing just one
last thing hey let me say one point
i want to make sure the record's clear
because you always say he's been out of
the league for three years yeah he
hasn't been out of the league for three
years he's been out for two seasons okay
three years ago he was playing for the
49ers sorry
missed two seasons yes but but that
extra i mean i'm just saying
it's easy for people to think he's been
out of the league for an extended period
of time he really hasn't been and ron
rivera could have his job riding on how
this season goes you have an owner who
did not buy the team because he wanted
to be able to say hey one of my
employees is ron rivera he wanted to buy
a football team and he may want his own
coach in there so ron rivera is going to
feel compelled to deliver some victories
and he looks at his current options
other than cam newton and he thinks
this doesn't give me a whole lot of
confidence and i'm going to win enough
games to save my butt so i think at some
level you weigh
distraction versus termination and maybe
that becomes a factor for ron rivera if
and we don't know at this
point ask the owner like you're saying
too the owner's gonna have to sign off
on this type of thing because it is
gonna bring an unbelievable amount of
attention to uh the whole situation and
everything like that
do we know that it will why are we
assuming that it will because we just
spent two weeks of news about jay-z
who's trying to make progress on the
subject and then went back to colin
kaepernick once again so we know it will
from that standpoint and two years out
of the nfl is a long time it really is
and it scares coaches that was my only
point there when i when i said three my
bad on that one right that's all right
that's all right but but anyway we'll
see how it plays out yes for now we
watch and we wait to see whether to what
extent cam newton has an injury that
will put his availability for week one
in play and if it is how much beyond
week one and who do they go with will
greer kyle allen taylor heinecke none of
those options are going to get people
all that excited except for me because i
want to see will grier do well because
he's a west virginia guy but even then
is he ready to go week one rookie season
that remains to be seen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports